hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast on Solaris novel open air
fluorescent imaging system for image
guided surgery applications
I am Brenda Kelly Kim of laggards and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's webcast is presented by lab Burt
the leading social media sites for
science professionals and sponsored by
PerkinElmer the leader in innovative
imaging detection and informatics
solutions before we start I just want to
show you a couple of features to ensure
you get the most out of this webinar we
want to hear from you during this
interactive broadcast so please ask
questions or leave the comment answers
welcome to you can do this by hitting
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window and typing in
your comments and questions we'll try to
get through as many as we can and we'll
follow up if we don't have time today
why better look you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you can hear or see
this presentation properly please let us
know by clicking on the support button
on the top right or use the Q&A button
we'll make sure we try to resolve any
issues now let's get right to today's
presenters we are proud to welcome dr.
yl you read our MV leaders in life
science technology at PerkinElmer and
dr. Jeffery Peterson director of Applied
biology at PerkinElmer dr. your read
leads all research and product
development activities for PerkinElmer
life science technologies division and
is the founding director of the
company's new center for personalized
health innovation in the Boston area
dr. --red also leads the company's
clinical translation programs for invivo
Diagnostics in collaboration with
strategic partners
prior to joining joining PerkinElmer dr.
your read with chief technology officer
for vision medical where he led the
development of fluorescence molecular
tomography and vis in molecular agent
portfolio he holds a PhD in engineering
from the Massachusetts Institute
technology dr. Peterson when he received
his PhD in immunology and neuroscience
from Northwestern University where his
research was focused on autoimmune
diseases including multiple sclerosis
and type 1 diabetes after finishing his
degree dr. Peterson worked as a
scientist at Boehringer Ingelheim and
Abbott bio research where he read led
development of novel drugs therapies and
biomarkers dr. Peterson has been leading
research efforts in fluorescence imaging
for the past nine years at Suzanne
medical and then PerkinElmer developing
novel imaging agents and applications in
preclinical research models hello
everyone it's a pleasure to welcome you
to our webinar on the Sedaris imaging
platform this is why I've added I will
give you a description of the Solaris
imaging system technology hardware and
software highlighting is human
performance attributes of the technology
and then we hand it over to my colleague
dr. Jeffrey Pearson who would provide a
few electrical applications readable
innovative situations let me begin by
describing personnel MERS in vivo
imaging preclinical imagery portfolio
which is a broad and rich portfolio of
instrument platforms that go all the way
from aniconic imaging for example with
the quantum DX which provides fast mode
of high throughput revolution computed
tomography readouts to a functional and
metabolic platform and for example the
best x-ray or CT platform that we have
right into the Sophie bar system to
develop and commercialize all the way to
our optical molecular imaging platforms
exemplified by the either saline or the
other spectrum and SMT instruments what
these platforms share in common is that
they're all designed for
animals and that's the mainstay of
preclinical imaging in both drug
development and research and of course
what the small animal imaging and not
really introduces is the possibility of
the Clio's
imaging chamber which provides the
instrument and the user with the
benefits of the three controlled optical
environment in contrast with this our
large animal imaging is is not able to
benefit from having this religion
chamber and to remedy this gap we
developed the Solaris imaging
instruments and that's what I'd love to
talk about today so Solaris is a large
animal and translational energy platform
by virtue of the anatomy of the animal
that it's imaging it needs to operate in
the open air Indian environment with
ancient lighting and like the rest of
our preclinical energy portfolio Solaris
comes complete with a portfolio of
illegal ferocious molecular agents which
we'll talk about where one of the
preview tation and of course it comes
with the best set of applications going
on the deep expertise we've developed
over the years at PerkinElmer this is
the research shoes only platform it's a
key performance attribute that it does
refine imaging a fluorescence as well as
white light and overlays III it can do
this at vimeo same rates or high
sensitivity snapshot imaging its ability
to reject agent light is is based on the
surgical grade luminaires that are
designed in the instrument it is it
covers a number of excitation channels
it has broad spectral coverage which
will detail in a minute and provides
both hardware and algorithmic controls
of lighting in order to reject alien
client and all of this is resting on a
foundation of protein animals expertise
in preclinical imaging expertise and
molecular imaging and image analysis and
our depth and blood cells
ng
expertise and instrument design software
and and imaging agents and we currently
have a number of instruments in in in
current use before we dive into the
technology itself I just wanted to give
you a very quick thumbnail description
of some of the key applications we
envision for Solaris which were which my
colleague will then taken much more
detail in a few minutes
but broadly speaking Solaris is an
instrument which is really designed to
provide pre-surgical guidance
surgical values for example delineation
of tumor margins and examination of
residual disease as well as both
surgical guidance for example
examination of the surgical cavity and
providing values to pathologists it has
applications spanning a number of the
intra disease areas for example oncology
atherosclerosis inflammatory processes
in arthritis vaccine development and
genetic safety and pharmacology
assessment and in all these cases the
signal is mediated by a molecular agent
which is targeted with certain biology
so different energy biomarkers for
example include integrins proteases such
as an empiric acceptance are or other
cell surface receptor and these are
could be key targeted by the portfolio
agents which we will illustrate later on
so what are the features of Solaris as
an instrument first and foremost I would
say it is very easy to use both the
hardware and the software were designed
to operate in a very busy surgical
suites and therefore they support a
truly a true surgical workflow so the
instrument is operated by a tablet has a
very simple touchscreen interface then
workflow makes it easy to acquire
snapshots or real-time videos the
instrument has two large medical grade
monitors for enhanced resolution and
color fidelity and provides easy
one-handed adjustment of the image
had wolf autofocus when needed the
second key feature the instrument is
that I provide surgical grade
illumination in both white light and
fluorescence and the broad spectral
coverage facilitates preclinical and
translation of years and that spectral
coverage includes a short syllable
channel at 420 nanometers of excitation
a couple of reds and in near infrared
channels at 669 meters and 750
nanometers excitation and is slightly
deeply infrared channel at 800 nanometer
excitation and those four channels
supports a broad range of values and
agents going from 14-under on the short
end of the spectrum all the way to
induce only in green or ICG on the long
end of the spectrum and then finally
another unique feature of the instrument
hardware and software is its ability to
acquire multispectral images and the
image deconvolution in order to
attenuate out of fluorescence where are
fluorescence is a problem mainly in the
short visible band of the front and 70
nanometer channel and this is done using
a proprietary liquid crystal tunable
filter technology so looking a little
bit more closely at the design of the
half of the optical heads the optical
head provides all of the optics
electronics and mechanical components
that are used for illumination and
imaging and factoring with elimination
we provide a number of elimination
modules in both white light and
fluorescence they are distributed high
power LED sub assemblies specifically 10
of these modules for each heads and with
any each of these modules we have 20
high brightness white light LEDs and for
expectation abbs corresponding to the 4
channels this arrangement we've designed
in order to maximize uniformity of
illumination
provide good control control of shadows
and good management of the thermal load
the fluorescence detector is
is a high-grade F CMOS camera that can
run at very high frame rates with fan
pixel resolution and low levels of noise
and likewise we use the high performance
CMOS detector should a white light or
color band in overnight so what were
some of the considerations that went
into the design of the illuminator we
wanted to make sure that we provided
very good illumination uniformity across
all of the spectral bands and that's
really the critical delineators in the
pattern that you see here we also wanted
to minimize shadows projected onto the
surgical cavity from both external and
internal sources external sources such
as surgical tool is an example and 800
sources such as protruding or or
cavities within the surgical bug excels
and you'll see some examples of those on
the next slide we also wanted to of
course reject any light which we do be
able spectrum and temporal means and
dissipate heat properly and so as an
example of how you being able to meet
these design objectives what you see
here is is a measurement and and result
of the illuminated performance from the
for the uniformity perspective so we
achieve white light brightness that is
equivalent to surgical luminaires we
illuminate a field of view of twenty by
twenty centimeters which is double the
size of the imaging field of view of ten
by ten centimeters and we provide lower
than ten percent variation of
illumination over the entire imaging
field with you which gives the user the
assurance that the signal they're
getting is is corresponding accurately
to the floor for concentration in the
visual rather than to hotspots and we
and electing itself
we've also optimized the control of
shadows we have a snap for angle in the
machine on the working surface and
inside the surgical channels and a
couple of diagrams you see on the lower
right hand side of the flag gives you
measurement of these shadows under
various conditions
likewise moving from the white light
illumination to the fluorescent
illumination we provide two assets
excitation optics to cover this broad
band going from the Schwartz available
at 470 all the way to 800 nanometers we
provide both temporal and spectral
radiance keys for the excitation and
emulation LEDs to reject England likely
the the diagram on the top left side
shows you the spectral data and shows
you the most popular excitation and
initially dry spectrum corresponding to
the various channels and the series of
photographs underneath I showed you the
effect of the temporal gating process we
we we follow to subtract and divide from
the background and result in a very
specific signal in the foreground we
also as I mentioned provide a three
stage liquid crystal to the base rated
to handle all the fluorescence in the
visible range this cell sweeps across
the number of wavelengths in that
channel acquires the images and then
subtracts automatically our presence of
tissue in that band from the
contribution of the floor for all of
this is encapsulated in an optical head
the head is mounted on a articulated arm
that provides three degrees of feeling
for adjustment and in your kitchen roll
with a broad range of motion that makes
it easier to move the head that just
ahead on the subject regardless of the
orientation of the subject there is
gross positioning as well as fine
positioning and of course auto focus is
provided within that instrument as well
then the handles are fully comparable we
explore all that so that they can so
that the optical have can be comfortably
mounted about the surgical bed
say a few things about the software
again the key design objectives here as
a simple and streamlined workflow
oriented emphasize the software is based
on an advanced architecture which will
be supportive edged of GLP and 21 CFR
part 11 compliance and it is based on a
distributed architecture which itself
will enable a robust fault tolerance and
recovery as well as the opponent across
multiple machines and cloud-based
sharing and data management what you see
in the screenshot of the software is the
simple top level user interface with the
imaging viewports two of them as a
matter of fact the one on the left
happens to show an overlay of
fluorescence with white light the one on
the right shows just the white light
image and various presentations can be
applied by the end-user in terms of
operating the instruments via the tablet
it's a very simple user interface again
that begins left to right from setting
up an imaging session then selecting an
imaging channel whether it's for 76 67
50 or 800 selecting a field with you and
then simply start into image and when
you start to image you have the ability
to acquire snapshots record videos
thousand which is real imaging at any
point in time as you're imaging zooming
in zooming out and rotating the images
in order to maximize the facility of
imaging and accomplish in a complex and
cluttered surgical environment once
imaging has been acquired the data can
be managed quite readily with both
videos and snapshots we have simple user
interface and data hierarchy that is
those who look for research environments
with a hierarchy of studies subjects and
sessions that allow you to retrieve and
manipulate and analyze all of the data
and you'll see some examples of those
analyses later on in the presentation to
give you a sense of the imaging
performance of this instrument we
catalyze it across a number of Cuba
nations first and foremost of course is
the resolution of energy and we designed
high quality optics into the instruments
so we have a family solution that is
enabled by diffraction limited optics we
currently resolve 100 microns
at the same time tell me refugee which
was our original target and we've
actually exceeded that target quite
substantially but this allows us to
image super cellular aggregates in a
surgical patient in an animal that is
fully intact and breathing a second key
specs for such a platform is its
sensitivity under aiming to illumination
and that is a very important requirement
and so we set up to hit a certain
sensitivity expect we've actually
managed to exceed that spec and we
currently are able to detect lower than
10 nano molar of floor for concentration
across all the channels in snapshot made
under full Ament illumination and we're
able to detect fewer than 50 nano molar
a.44 concentration across all channels
at full video frame rates again under
full agent illumination and this is
illustrated by the bar graph on the
right it was all the channels and a
snapshot of the well played experiment
is shown to the right of that just to
give you a sense how these measurements
were acquired and you are currently able
as I mentioned to detect very trace
trace on upper floors under full ancient
illumination tissue penetration is an
important requirement and we have to
shoot penetration capability that is
sufficient to visualize subsurface
signals the the toughest spectral band
here is deformed infant anatomy tube and
because of the properties of biological
tissue and were able to penetrate a few
millimeters of tissue in that band and
as you go deeper and the web and then
your infrared you of course able to
achieve deeper penetration so as a
couple of examples shown on the right
hand side
we show you a simple experiment we've
done
dead tissue and a couple of our ages the
Integra sense agent and the 680
nanometer Channel and the intelligence
agents on the 750 nanometers Channel and
has placed these agents in small
sentence given slices of dead tissue at
increasing death's energy concei were
able to detect signal quite comfortably
in the six to nine millimeter banks so
certainly enough signal to grow through
folds of tissue as well as subcutaneous
and surface detection and broadly
speaking we've validated the performance
of the instrument under open air related
conditions under a wide range of agents
and surgical in termination and to
include this part of the presentation of
the technology itself I just wanted to
mention that Solaris fits along a
continuum of PerkinElmer offerings that
go from the biochemical and cell fa
range with nucleic acid and protein
detection to cellular imaging and
detection into small animal imaging and
tissue imaging and now we've added large
animal and translational imaging to that
portfolio and with that what I'd like to
do is hand it over to my colleague dr.
Jeffrey garrison we'll walk you through
a number of key specifications that his
group have been able to develop ok so
now I'm going to share with you some of
our Solaris application work that we
generated a PerkinElmer is Research
Center in Hopkinton Massachusetts dr.
Eric described research on the solaris
requires pairing the imaging system and
the fluorescence imaging agents and
together they provide an important tool
for studying a variety of disease
processes and biological activities
designed for large animal research but
also readily applicable to Mouse in that
research and all of our animal work
however is performed as proof of concept
for our ultimate goal of large animals
translation so some of the key
applications that dr. gray Vanover do
include oncology arthritis half the
Earth's closest
safety pharmacology and we have a
variety of near-infrared fluorescent
imaging agents that detect different
aspects
biological changes in the relevant
animal models I'll show you some of the
data we generated in oncology
drug-induced liver injury and lymphatic
draining generated in mice and rats so
I'm going to start by briefly
introducing you to some of our imaging
agents and the applications that have
been developed over the years using
small animal imaging systems like are
either spectrum CT and fmt 4000 then
I'll move on to the application data
with this allowance so first of all to
introduce you to these imaging agents we
have a variety of them that are readily
applicable to cancer imaging and these
fall into three three or four basic
categories so I'll start by describing
the activatable agents which are as
shown in the cartoon optically silent in
their native state so when we inject
these systemically into the animal they
circulate through the animal they're
going everywhere and when they go to the
site of disease where you may have up
regulated proteases the agent itself is
cleaved luden to AD quenching of the
agent and a fluorescent on signal and
these agents include our matrix
metalloproteinase activatable agents
like our NM t sense agents our
conception family activatable agents
called pro sense and we have some
selective Kotetsu inactivated like cafe
in cat view as well for select
applications other activatable agents
like neutrophil elastase green and
activatable and prostate specific
antigen activatable agents as well to
round out the portfolio all of these
quite useful for cancer because many of
these proteases are very important both
in cancer itself as far as the
aggressiveness of cancer and approaching
into host tissue as well as being
important in the inflammatory component
of cancer as well now we have also
targeted agents that are relevant in
cancer these differ from the activatable
agents in that these agents are
constitutively fluorescents are waiting
for them to bind to their target
accumulate there and then
the unbound material will eventually
wash away so you can image these a
little bit differently but there's a
similar premise and these include agents
that are ranging from very small
molecule targeting moieties with a
fluorophore label to larger molecules so
I'll go over in particular some data
with our Integra sense agent that was
developed as a collaboration with Merck
using a small molecule immigrant
antagonist we also have other agents
that pick up changes in bone like our
Ostia sense cell death that occurs in a
variety of conditions with our necks in
vivo we can do bacterial imaging and we
can pick up other aspects of biology
such as hypoxia in cancer with our oxy
sense we have a labeled trust in lab
also a collaboration with Roche that
allows us to detect her to a new
expression and then we have some
different agents like folate our sense
bombas in our sense and transfer in vivo
that allow us to detect metabolic
changes in cancer attributed to changes
in expression levels of folate receptor
bombazine receptor and transferrin
receptor the last category of imaging
agents is our physiologic agents this is
predominantly vascular agents that are
again constitutively fluorescent but
they're not targeted so they're going to
flow where the blood flows so they're
going to accumulate excites a vascular
leak in cancer for example or at sites
of edema associated with inflammation
and then a final category would be our
label so you if you have a protein
therapeutic of some sort
when antibody you can put a near
infrared label on those and be able to
track those in people as well going to
your sites of disease we also have the
capability of labeling cells with our
vivo tract 680 agent so many of these
are also not just useful for cancer but
can pick up inflammation as I described
and we've also moved into doing basic
pharmacology to do biodistribution and
pharmacokinetics as I described with
your own
agents and more recently we've
identified some of these imaging agents
that are quite useful in picking up
changes in tissues associated with toxic
insult by drugs for example so now here
is kind of a Lisa snapshot of the world
of applications that we've developed
using our small animal imaging boxes or
IVA spectrum CT and FM TVs for example
and these cover a whole variety of
different types of areas and including
in cancer here where we're using some of
our agents to pick up metabolic changes
looking at treatment efficacy we've been
able to also multiplex some of our
agents to see different types of
biological changes in cancer
simultaneously we've been able to look
at pharmacokinetics by non-invasive
imaging of the heart a whole body by
distribution studies pulmonary
inflammation arthritis toxicology and
even into CNS de myelination as well we
also have tools and bioluminescence that
we're not going to talk about today that
give us the ability to take
bioluminescent cancer in our small
animal models and quantify changes in
growth or response to therapy so some of
these agents have been identified for us
to focus on for our Solaris work and
these include some of the agents listed
here and these include our angio sense
680 X agent which is great for looking
at tumor vascular link and inflammatory
edema as I described earlier and we've
also found it quite useful for looking
at a lymphatic drainage we've looked at
sort of experimental models of lymphatic
drainage and going to lymph nodes
identifying in codes we're also working
on the same application in cancer and
I'll show you some of the data we
generated today our MMP and cathepsin
activatable agents and MP sense and pro
sense quite useful and can
again our Integra cents very good for
detecting alpha beta 3 immigrant
expression and our full-length agent for
detecting metabolic changes associated
with folate uptake now a lot of the work
we've done that I'm really not going to
share with you today has been geared
towards identifying the right doses for
imaging on the Solaris imaging system we
know for example in the mouse that we
lead aidan in animals per kilogram body
weight in order to effectively
non-invasively image through the animal
whether by tomography or doing
superficial 2d imaging when we start
extrapolating the larger animals and in
the context of doing surgical imaging on
the solaris imaging system we now
realize that we can drop that dose a
little bit on a per kilogram amount down
to 24 in animals per kilogram so that
keeps some of the doses down to a
reasonable level and we characterize
this both ourselves to some degree and
to collaborations so now I'm going to
give you a little bit of a snapshot of
one of the agents I'm not going to go
through all of them today but this one
I'll talk about to a fair degree with
some of our imaging data sets
it's our Integra sense imaging aging I
mentioned this as an agent Lee developed
in collaboration with Merck it's
designed from a small molecule integral
antagonist at Merck developed and we
work for about a year and a half in
developing the ability to identify a
conjugation site and a appropriate
linker for us to put a floor floor that
allows us to function as a imaging agent
for cancer and certain types of
inflammation so alpha v beta 3 integrand
is upregulated in a whole variety of
cancers many of them there are some in
which it does not but most cancers we
find quite good for alpha 2 beta 3
upregulation and we can see it expressed
both in the tumors as well as in vessels
that are newly formed and it's also
expressed in certain types of macrophage
inflammation so what we've seen that the
application level is it's quite useful
for both oncology applications as well
as atherosclerosis and there are a few
other applications as well
in osteoclasts imaging as well one of
the nice things about this aging is
although it's a small molecule agent it
is internalized into cells through
receptor mediated endocytosis and it
allows us to have a good imaging window
for labeling those cells in vivo they
uptake it and hold on to this agent for
quite a while so now just a little bit
of a description on tumor biology
obviously the what's happening in tumors
is quite complex there's a lot of
different biological activities from the
obvious metabolism and proliferation of
tumor cells to spontaneous apoptosis and
necrosis that can occur in the growing
cancer as well as it when you're
treating with certain therapeutics will
obviously enhance the cellular Gaffin
and necrosis that occurs in tissue
there's hypoxia there's vascular leak
associated with the angiogenesis that
occurs in tumors and of course there's a
lot of information that goes on and a
lot of proteases that are produced by
burries inflammatory cells as well as by
the tumor cells and even within the
blood vessels there are markers that we
can go after that allow us to see these
so as an example you know one of the
things we can look at in molecular
imaging context is vascular leak with an
agent like an geofence that sees certain
regions of the tumor often broadly
spread through the tumor a vascular leak
associated with the angiogenesis of
securing there and we've been able to
successfully use this agent to detect
not only this askew leak that a response
to anti a with anti angio genic
therapies now most relevant I think for
the Solaris imaging system where our
goal is really to have a tool for being
able to very effectively visualize the
tumors and identify the tumor margins so
one of the best ways to do that is to
have agents that label the entire tumor
quite well and a couple of these agents
that we've really focused on include our
pro sense agents that seeing
predominantly conception B although a
family
substance that generally are distributed
throughout the tumor and within the
inflammatory cells throughout the tumor
Integra sends in a similar manner C's
alpha beta 3 immigrant expression on
tumors throughout the tumor cells
throughout the tumor so gives you a
great way of not only seeing the primary
tumor but also tumor MEPs that may be
either proximal or distal to a primary
tumor mass so now on to the solaris
imaging system you've seen a few images
already I wanted to give you a sense of
the system at work so you can see here
someone on the left image
focusing on an animal in the surgical
site you can see it's very brightly
illuminated as a matter of fact it's
very very difficult to take good
pictures of the system at work because
the light is so bright at the surgical
site that it's very hard to actually see
the animal from the distance and you can
see that at the bottom right here how
bright that light is on the animal yet
if we allow a shorter exposure time you
can see the rat quite readily makes the
room look very dark and in the upper
right you can see what it looks like
when you have the mo gray have really
illuminated with the white light but yet
you can see on the computer monitor
there's quite easily able to see the
fluorescent signal in the animal that's
being visualized so under the bright
surgical lights we're able to do
real-time acquisition of live us and
signal occurring within the animal
oftentimes mam and basically we can see
a certain depth into the animal the
other thing that we can do in refining
this quite useful is rapid screening of
hand restrained animals even without
anesthesia obviously likely more small
animal works and this is quite helpful
we're finding for just rapidly screening
through animals that we want to triage
for going into our small animal imaging
systems so just a a couple of things
that we worked out is just to exemplify
how the system works obviously not only
are the surgical lights on but we have
lights on in the room as well and it
doesn't affect us
at all you can see in the upper panels
here that even with all the room lights
on the fluorescent signal with our
Integra sent 750 here lighting up a
tumor on the flank of this mouse lights
it up quite well and you can see there
is some general bodily signal attributed
to the agent circulating through all the
tissues of the body we see very nice
accumulation that the system can detect
quite readily in that Bank sight even in
the presence of all the room lights when
the room lights are off you really can't
tell that it's any different at all so
now an example of a real-life utility
for this system we've done a lot of work
in rats as a proof of concept for moving
on to larger animals obviously a rat is
not that large but large enough for us
to get some of these concepts in
performing surgical intervention
resection of tumors etc so what I've
done here is show a study that we did
with parrot merely implanted HTT one one
six tumor cells that were tending to
grow in a very local site very close to
the spleen and relatively close to the
surface of the animal so when we go in
we can acquire video of our entire
surgical procedure I just grabbed some
snapshots from the real-time video
acquisition so you can see here in the
upper left this is just the non-invasive
imaging we applied a little bit of
thresholding to remove some of that
background a type signal that you saw in
the last image and you can see a very
nicely defying region that we attribute
to the tumor that's growing just in the
perineum near the spleen we can then
drape the animal for surgery here and
you can still see that tool early we
wash the surgical site we then progress
to performing the incision in the animal
to expose the tumor and on the far right
you see the animal completely open we
remove the tumor you can see that signal
quite nicely as the tumor is removed and
we can examine the surgical site and
ascertain whether there is any
additional tumor
there and the video goes on to pulling
the spleen out and exposing it fully to
make sure there's no mass is growing
within the screen and we can close the
animal back up and and look at that
animal later time points by really
ejected with that Integra sense a couple
weeks later or a couple months later
even so we do see a depth dependent
capability for our non-invasive
detection certainly if it's much deeper
it can be more challenging but we do see
relatively well that into the animal and
with proper background thresholding you
can see really very nicely we can apply
some quantitative tools to this as well
by placing our lies in there in real
time or on the snapshots that we acquire
here just shows an example of comparing
the signal non-invasively and after
sizing the tumor as compared to
irrelevant control size either on the
flank of the animal or within the
surgical site and we're seeing in this
particular model with with a fairly
small tumor that was near the spleen
about a 1.7 fold signal-to-noise ratio
so now we've moved on also to other
types of surgical models in-between
wanted to assess the capability of
identifying tumors and defining the the
tumor margins as well as following up
these animals to see if we were able to
get all of that tumor mass and remove it
and to do that we did a study where we
implanted subcutaneous into 29:2 mer
cells into mu rats and we perform
survival surgery and here you can see a
sequence of images from preoperative
imaging both in white light and
fluorescence and you can see there's a
tumor mass below the skin surface we can
expose the tumor and see it readily we
can remove the tumor surgically we can
then examine the site where the tumor
was and close it up and you can see that
there's no residual signal left within
that tumor site as a control we could
take another animal where we
incomplete tumor resection to see what
that would look like where we did the
same sequence of events the preoperative
imaging exposing the tuna removing the
tumor only in this case we removed only
part of the tumor and left a little bit
of the tumor mass approximately the
fifths of the tumor left and you can see
that it's that residual tumor is still
there and even after we close the
animals we can see a little bit of an
indication that there is some residual
tumor mass remaining just another
example here is looking at full depths
of imaging in an animal we did this by
necropsy in the rat just so we could
open the animal wide and really look
around for different tumor masses so
again we can start from the pre-op where
you can see some indication that there
are some deep tissue masses when we
remove the skin we can see a little bit
deeper into the animal we can identify
some additional masses that are there
once we completely expose the cavity we
start seeing some higher resolution as
we pull back the peritoneal lining
we could see some masses that were
attached to the peritoneal lining we
could see some very small nodules as
well within the site and remove oliver's
we could still see a small neck still
remaining that we could then remove in
the sequence of events and one thing I'd
like to point out when we do this this
type of imaging and trying to identify
both primary masses and necks it is
important which agent you select here's
an example where when we use our
bombazine receptor detecting agent we
had a lot of interference from the
intestinal region because that's a known
site of bombas and receptor upregulation
when we switch to percent 750 fast
detecting cathepsin activity and the
tumors we see nice signal in the tumor
masses and very little signal remaining
in the intestines so now I'm going to
briefly go over a couple of quick
applications one in lymph node draining
and the other and acute drug-induced
liver injury
so here here is a sequence of captured
stills from a video that was acquired
where we injected an geofence 680 X into
the tale base and watch it moving up the
lymphatics into the first being inguinal
lymph node and then progressing up into
the axial lymph node and you can see
really quite well very well-defined
lymphatics and in the video you can
actually see the pulsing of these
lymphatics as discrete masses of
fluorescents are propagated along the
lymphatics and into the lymph nodes and
of course importantly when we place a
point our allies on those lymph node
sites we can actually quantify this both
in real time as we're acquiring the
videos but also in snapshots that we can
collect as well and you can quantify
that there's a rapid progression of
increase of signal in the inguinal lymph
node that peaks at about three minutes
and then starts declining as it's moving
out of that lymph node and some of that
material is propagating on to the axial
lymph node the axial is nodes shown in
yellow below is peaking at about five
minutes two minutes later and it's not
doesn't look as bright but also that's
because the axial node is a little bit
deeper in the tissue it's under the arm
web of the animal so you're clearly able
to see the differential kinetics going
into these two different lymph nodes the
obvious application of this is being
able to both identify and quantify lymph
node drainage camere by nodes there's
another example of lymphatic draining
here injecting into a different site
just to show you that you can get a
different pattern of lymphatic draining
so when you inject a footpad here we see
progression and drainage into firstly
popliteal lymph node and then eventually
into the lumbar node and we can also
quantify that over time we can use this
as a tool for identifying those nodes
and
interviewing surgically and go in and
actually expose these nodes surgically
and then remove them as well so the last
application I want to quickly show is
some of our early safety pharmacology
work we've done a lot of work in this
area in developing imaging agents and
techniques for detecting liver talks
caused by a variety of different drugs
it's very important for pharmaceutical
companies to be able to screen small
molecule drugs for their potential for
toxicity and we've developed an imaging
cocktail that's composed of three
different new infrared fluorescent
imaging agents that allow us to see
multiple different types of liver talks
there are different forms of it
hepatocellular cholestasis which is a
bile duct blockage and fatty liver side
effects of drugs that's called steatosis
so with our cocktail of agents we were
able to see multiple of these different
types of mechanisms and that's
exemplified here by some data we
generated with a drug called v acid
amide we use three hundred and fifty
milligrams per kilogram of taa given
twice over a period of eight hours we
injected the imaging cocktail 24 hours
after the first injection and they've
inch 24 hours thereafter so first you
can see what the UH thresholded data
looks like where you can see a clear
difference between the control and the
Toa injected but once we apply some
modest threshold in based on the point
ROI we placed just outside of the
imaging field or the deliver region we
use that to apply special then we can
very nicely see the liver signagi the
mountain basically when we remove the
skin we can see that signal even better
and how well defined it is localizing
to the liver and then with a full
exposure of the liver you can see that
quite readily as well and when we apply
quantification to this we can see that
even in the intact animal even though
the deliver is a big organ and fairly
deep in the animal enough of it is
superficial
relatively close to the skin that we can
see a good differential between the
liver and background sites as you remove
the skin obviously you're going to get a
lot better differential
signal within that liver and of course
the ultimate ideal for the Solaris is
when you fully open the animal you get a
very nice dynamic range of detection of
that the ultimate application of this is
not just to focus on liver talks but to
use these this cocktail of agents to do
a new crop see of the animals and to
look at all of the different organ
systems and to identify whether they're
any red flags and different organ
systems that may be being affected by
your acute treatment at with your drug
so with that I'd like to end by
summarizing some of the work that we've
done with our solaris imaging system
it's allowed us to visualize fluorescent
signal in in a number of our small
animals and we have collaborators
working on larger animals which is the
ultimate application it offers a bright
imaging field with ambient light
rejection multiple channels of imaging
proprietary spectral I'm mixing
technology that allows us to better look
at some of those more visible florescent
channels has a very simple user
interface with real-time quantification
capabilities that allows us to
on-the-fly
see what's happening in different sites
of the body as we're acquiring our
videos has a utility in oncology and
multiple other research areas including
atherosclerosis arthritis vaccine
development and safety pharmacology as
we've discussed and just has a very easy
interface real time videos and snapshots
to acquire video and snapshot analysis
tools our in-house validation studies as
I described have focused predominantly
on mouse and rat however several
prototypes are currently in use for the
ultimate application and large animal
imaging so with that I'd like to open up
to any of the questions that you may
have submitted excellent presentation
dr. Yared and dr. Peterson thank you for
bringing that information to us before
we get started with the audience
questions here's a quick reminder about
how to reach us today questions can be
sent via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and we'll get to as many as we can
and our first question comes from Debbie
at the University of Oxford
what about autofluorescence at longer
wavelengths ie 600 Nm auto fluorescent
signal is quite large Baird shoes yes so
I can address that question that's there
that's a very good question we start
quite quite long about the spectral
coverage of the instrument and where we
wanted to introduce autofluorescence
removal technology and our assessment
was that of course this would be most
pertinent at the 479 meter channel fair
city the audience member is correct
there is indeed out of fluorescence
around 600 nanometer as well it is much
lower than a force intubated still
present nonetheless however our next
channel up has an excitation wavelength
of 660 nanometers it is targeted at dyes
that have a peak absorption wave like
the wavelength of 680 nanometers where
diminution the peaks at 700 to 750
nanometers and our depth emission
wavelength the autofluorescence is
sufficiently attenuated that we felt it
wasn't beneficial to introduce any
complexity spectral contribution on that
band and of course on the 750 and 800
bands
it is much lower solution on balance
that we've optimized the optical
performance of the system to provide
maximum benefit wait thank you our next
question comes from Mohammed at Barrow
Neurological Institute is it possible to
illuminate in different wavelengths
simultaneously so to be clear it is
possible to Co inject multiple agents on
multiple wavelengths into the same
animal at the same time in imaging
itself is conducted one channel at a
time but then during the images can be
overlaid across
four channels so we can conduct a
multi-channel experiment that the energy
itself is conducted one channel at a
time
great thank you our next question from
Xuan at smirk for the lymph node
draining studies how much dye was
injected at the sale base yeah typically
we inject in the range of about five
Nana moles per injection site now when
you start applying that to a tumor
lymphatic draining you would spread that
same five animals over multiple sites of
injection within the tumor and we try to
keep the volumes fairly low and you know
and that tends to work quite well going
up much higher gives you a very high
signal that can be often difficult to
deal with because you really have to
amplify the signal to see the smaller
amounts obviously that are leaking out
the doses that we're using are
compatible with what people have done
with - gene for example but we're
putting some data together that you know
does provide some sort of side by side
with some of the variety of agents we've
looked at and I think we're finding we
may even be able to go a little bit
lower thank you our next question from
Olga has Vitamix therapeutics with this
system Solaris be applicable to clinic
in the future are you expecting any
limitations or adjustments yeah so our
to be clear for now we are releasing
this instrument commercially for
research use only so we are not
dedicated in dedicating it to the clinic
it is possible as we study the the space
of applications and demand that we might
in the future engineer a version of the
Solaris instrument for clinical use
generally speaking clinical imaging
devices are are simpler and require
endless
sort of the futures that research
instruments or preclinical increments
have so it would be a simplification of
the existing architecture but for now
the Solaris instrument is for
researchers only thank you next up from
James Essen elsie jennes i'm have you
tried newly discovered brain lymphatic
channels no we haven't really done any
work in that area today we've been
focusing mostly on identifying and
optimizing the right agents for most
effectively defining the lymphatics and
we have been quite surprised to see just
how variable it can be and how much do
you have physical chemical properties of
the agent you inject can affect just how
well and effectively you can image the
lymphatics for example designing those
or selecting those that allow not only
detection of the lymph nodes but not
along too much linkage additives notice
a lot of them you find are giving a halo
effect around the nodes so most of our
works been there but we'll be advancing
into further applications as we move on
great
we have another question from Jack at UT
Health is there any influence on the
surgical lighted not to look typically
the surgical light is relatively strong
even at NIR yes
essentially the surgical lights do have
an influence on some buds of the
instrument but generally speaking as
Senate dr. Gerson's energy has has
demonstrated we can acquire images with
their lives built on and off with
and no effect on the qualification rate
our next question from James have you
tried litter toxin at any try deliver
time yeah we have really focused on on
drug-induced liver injury but many of
the same mechanisms that are involved in
responding to toxic drugs are going to
be similar or many of them applicable to
other types of liver injury including
infectious disease and toxins in this
type of thing but no we haven't yet
worked in that area at all
great I think our next question we have
comes in from
one moment comes in from Justin is such
a prototype available in Europe for
trials we can't have an early access
instrument in the earth but the
instrument would be more broadly
available in late summer this year
worldwide so that doesn't interrupt yes
great we have another question you have
four channels but only show images of
the signals at depth on the 660 and 750
channels do you expect the same
performance at depth for the 470 channel
with fitc and the 800 channel with ICG
right so generally tissue penetration
improves as you go into the near
infrared so we expect shallower
penetration in the 16 or 14 channel at
470 nanometers improve tissue
penetration at 650 nanometers and data
penetration at 750 and 800 nanometers so
I would expect the ICG channel to be
similar to the 750 channel in terms of
tissue penetration and depth detection
and the 470 channel to be more success
rate than than the others great another
question will other methods of agent
delivery IP or spray-on work with this
system yes we have explored that in
particular the spray-on approach can
work quite well we have other issues of
you know what particularly your spraying
on how you're washing it away because
obviously if you generate a lot of
signal on the surface of the animal that
can be issues IP is more of a question
of the pharmacology a lot of the
targeted agents that we use
would not fare very well by IPE unless
you're imaging something distal from the
IP space because we create a lot of
signal just localized in the IP space so
barring any sort of technical issues
that have little to do with the Solaris
yeah absolutely you should be able to
deal with any injection route that is
appropriate for the agent that you're
looking at and for the site that you're
imaging thank you our next question from
the leaf at ILC what is the maximum
depth and the largest animal that has
been imaged in a Solaris yeah I think on
the on the imaging sides anything that
can be placed on a surgical bed gave the
imaged on the Solaris the image and
field of view is 10 by 10 centimeters
and and the optical head can be moved
pretty readily on an articulated arm in
terms of the penetration that's that's a
question that win depends on these four
for the four for brightness and the
concentration and so it's not a the type
of question that is based on the
instrument design alone so it's a
combination of the instrument along
alongside the agent and the agent
delivery and clear lesser extent which
organ you're actually imaging what we're
comfortable is our ability to detect
fluorescence emanating from deep seated
lesions that are a few millimeters in
depth settling in the red and the
infrared channel but that's really
working with some of the agent that
we've mentioned such as Anderson's
integrations programs and others and
we'd be happy to look at some other
agents based on the utility and using
data from the type of application that
is that was of interest thank you very
much that is all the time we have for
questions today if we didn't get to
yours we will definitely follow you
follow up with you via email I would
like to thank our speakers dr. y le red
and dr. jeffery peterson today as well
as our sponsor
PerkinElmer for making it possible to
bring this presentation to you
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December 24
2015 and you'll receive an email from
laberd's alerting you when it's
available on demand and posted on
libraries calm you are welcome to
forward this announcement to any
colleagues who weren't able to join in
today
thank you for logging on and
participating in today's broadcast see
you next time